now to the aftermath of that trained
derailment in Ohio where local residents
are very reluctant to accept official
advice that it's safe to return home it
has been 12 days since the accident in
East Palestine since this talks sent
rather this toxic plume of smoke into
the air now people are complaining about
health issues and there are Urgent
questions about how their concerns were
handled Lilia Luciano has the story
I would be alert and and concerned but I
think I would probably be back in my
house that was Ohio Governor Mike
dewine's answer when he was asked
whether he would move back back home if
he lived in East Palestine Ohio though
he did offer caveats I think that I
would be drinking the bottled water
there have been numerous reports in
recent days of respiratory issues
burning eyes and dead Wildlife including
at least 3 500 confirmed dead fish
killed by contamination we don't have
any evidence of non-aquatic species
suffering from the derailment five of
the train cars were carrying Vinyl
chloride a highly combustible chemical
linked to a higher risk of some kinds of
cancers Crews conducted a controlled
release of the carcinogen to reduce the
risk of an explosion when you have
combustion or burning you create all
sorts of different byproducts it's
important to understand to cast a wide
net when you're testing because you want
to narrow out and rule out chemicals
that could pose an acute health risk or
linger around the governor and other
officials lifted the the town's
evacuation order a week ago after Health
officials said air quality was back to
acceptable levels and the city's main
water supply they said was safe two days
after the evacuation order was lifted
the EPA said three additional hazardous
chemicals were found on the derailed
train cars this train apparently was not
considered a high hazardous material
train yesterday Governor dewine revealed
that since only 20 of the 150 cars
contained hazardous materials the
company citing federal law was not
required to notify the state of Ohio
that the train had toxic chemicals on
board frankly if this is true and I'm
told it's true this is absurd for CBS
mornings I'm Lilia Luciano